[Musique]
l'histoire de madame l'appui
e
[Musique]
aujourd'hui deuxième épisode
de santé
et
ça s'est passé
[Musique]
m
et
t
l'arrivée du nouveau coq bouleversa tous
le poulailler
tout le monde se demandait ce qui allait
arriver
les poules avec curiosité le vieux coq
avec angoisse
[Musique]
il n'y a pas à dire on mangera du coq au
vin à la ferme
pourtant il n'y a pas fait que je sache
je ne sais pas si on mangera du coq au
vin
il sera sûrement meilleur que la poule
au pot que vous deviendrez sous peu
[Musique]
bobo pop rock coco le rêve de ma vie
mais vraiment je suis trop jeune l'heure
du dîner est en venu suzy la fille du
fermier apporte le grain aux poules en
compagnie de ses frères robin et bruno
il pénètre dans le poulailler et admire
le nouveau coq est presque aussi beau
que le père de notre vieux coq
moi je crois qu'il est plus vous une le
plus beau le plus beau il est aussi beau
toujours des paroles vexante le soir
tombe
[Musique]
lendemain matin john autre vieux coq
toujours levé le premier attend que son
successeur s'éveille pour annoncer leur
or ils ne bougent pas quelques semaines
c'est beau la jeunesse mais le travail
ce travail
cocorico
dans la forêt proche tout vit déjà les
oiseaux l'api le coucou la tribu des
belettes
et le petit 1 qui dans cet échange
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de santé
et
[Musique]
adieu
et
[Musique]
méfiez vous si le renard
heureusement vous êtes tous là comme
maire
heureusement si j'étais pas là vous
auriez tous mangé les spas corbeau
allons ne vous battez pas le renard est
toujours affamé il faut donc s'en méfier
et si madame l'api ne se réveillait pas
tous qui vous préviendrai coucou coucou
seule lame et égale le renard n'aime pas
les coco cocoon que tu dis madame l'api
ne parlait pas grossièrement haut
[Musique]